WATCHING TOMORROW.
THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT ALL IS NOT WELL AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
INFLATION RECORD LEVELS.
BUSINESSES CAN'T FIND EMPLOYEES.
MORE LOCKDOWNS ARE IMMINENT EVEN
SUPPORTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
A SOUTHERN BORDER IS A DISASTER.
VIOLENT CRIME IS RISING IN EVERY
MAJOR CITY IN THIS COUNTRY.
RUSSIA IS HACKING CRITICAL
SUPPLY LINES EVERY MONTH.
CHINA IS OPENLY THREATENING THE
UNITED STATES, OUR MILITARY AND
OUR ALLIES.
IRAN IS BACK TO ENRICHING
URANIUM ONE AND THE WITHDRAWAL
FROM AFGHANISTAN IS A DEBACLE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
UNRAVELLING FASTER THAN WE
EXPECTED.
57% OF AMERICANS SEE WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT AND FEW
OTHERS HAVE.
58% OF INDEPENDENTS AND A THIRD
OF DEMOCRATS SEE IT.
SO DOES AMERICA'S ENEMIES.
THE ONE THING THAT MOST AGREE
ON.
IT'S NOT JOE BIDEN RUNNING THE
SHOW.
TODAY YET AGAIN HE STRUGGLED TO
GET WORDS OUT DURING HIS ONE AND
ONLY PUBLICLY SCHEDULE EVENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE WENT FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE, TO --
TO BRING BIN LADEN TO THE GATES
OF HELL AS I SAID AT THE SAME
TIME.
THE SECOND REASON WAS TO
ELIMINATE AL-QAEDA'S CAPACITY TO
DEAL WITH MORE ATTACKS ON THE
UNITED STATES FROM THAT
TERRITORY.
WE ACCOMPLISHED BOTH OF THOSE
OBJECTIVES, PERIOD.
>> Sean: REPEAT, MAYBE WHEN YOU
GET TO 10-1,000 JOE WILL SPEAK.
YOU OPPOSED THE RAID TO GET BIN
LADEN.
I CAN NO LONGER LAUGH.
I CAN'T JOKE ABOUT BIDEN'S
COGNITIVE STRUGGLE.
EVERYONE CAN SEE HE IS IN BAD
SHAPE.
OUR ALLIES AND ENEMIES SEE AND
THE  MAJORITY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE IT.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
HE NEEDS CARDS EVEN AFTER
A DRIVE BRIEFING FROM THE STAFF.
HE IS TRYING TO BARELY GET
THROUGH THE ONE SCHEDULE EVENT A
DAY.
IT'S PATHETIC.
HERE'S THE NEXT OBVIOUS
QUESTION:
WHO IS MAKING THE DECISIONS?
WHO KNEW WHAT WHEN ABOUT JOE'S
CONDITION?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT JOE BIDEN.
THIS IS FROM 2012.
YOU WILL NOTICE TWO THINGS IN
THIS CLIP.
ONE JOE BIDEN BRAGS ABOUT BEING
AGAINST THE BIN LADEN RAID AND
TWO, JOE BIDEN WAS IN
A DIFFERENT COGNITIVE STATE IN
2012 THAN HE IS TODAY.
YOU DECIDE.
>> HE SAID WHAT IS YOUR OPINION?
THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND ENDED
WITH ME.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THAT ROOM
HEDGED THEIR BET EXCEPT LEON
PENETTA.
HE SAID GO.
EVERYONE ELSE SAID 49, 51.
JOE WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I SAID I DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD SO
MANY COMMUNISTS AROUND THE
TABLE.
WE KNOW THE MAN A DIRECT ANSWER.
MY SUGGESTION IS DON'T GO.
>> Sean: DON'T GO.
THAT JOE BIDEN IS LONG GONE.
TODAY'S WEAK AND FRAIL AND
COGNITIVELY STRUGGING BIDEN IS
GETTING STEAM ROLLED BY
AMERICA'S ENEMIES.
WE SHOWED YOU CHINA'S THREATS
AGAINST AMERICAN AND JAPANESE
MILITARY BASES.
CHINA IS TALKING ABOUT
REUNIFYING WITH TAIWAN AND
WARNING OF CONSEQUENCES IF
AMERICA HELPS OUR ALLY.
WE COVERED THE CYBER ATTACKS
FROM RUSSIA AND IRAN'S URANIUM
ENRICHMENT PROGRAM.
THE NUMBER 1 STATE SPONSOR OF
TERROR.
NONE FEAR OR RESPECT JOE BIDEN.
NEITHER DID THE TALIBAN.
AS AMERICA WITHDRAWS FORCES FROM
AFGHANISTAN, WE HAVE TALIBAN
EXTREMIST MOVES IN QUICKLY.
THEY ARE SEIZING U.S. WEAPONS
AND SUPPLIES IN THE PROCESS.
THEN THE QUESTION IS:
WHY ON EARTH WOULD WE EVER LEAVE
WEAPONS BEHIND LIKE THIS KNOWING
THE TALIBAN WOULD GET AHOLD OF
IT?
THAT'S MADNESS.
TODAY BIDEN WAS ASKED IF HE
TRUSTED THE TALIBAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DO YOU TRUST
THE TALIBAN?
>> IS THAT A SERIOUS QUESTION.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> NO, I DO NOT.
I DO NOT TRUST THE TALIBAN.
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THAT'S A SILLY QUESTION.
>> Sean: WHY DID YOU LIVE
WEAPONS BEHIND?
JEN PSAKI HAD A MESSAGE ON
AFGHANISTAN THAT WAS WORSE THAN
HIM.
SHE SAID THERE WOULD BE NO
CELEBRATION FOR THE TROOPS
COMING HOME BECAUSE THE WAR HAD
NOT BEEN WON MILITARILY.
OKAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN TERMS OF PLANS FOR THE END
FOR OUR MEN AND WOMEN COMING
BACK.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
PREVIEW.
WE WON'T HAVE A MISSION
ACCOMPLISHED MOMENT.
IT'S A 20 YEAR WAR THAT HASN'T
BEEN WON MILITARILY.
>> Sean: IF THE WAR WAS LOST,
THERE IS ONLY ONE REASON AND
IT'S A POLITICAL ONE.
BLAME JOE, YOUR BOSS.
MILITARILY THE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT FOUGHT IN AFGHANISTAN
AND DECIMATED AL-QAEDA AND
FOUGHT TO MAINTAIN ORDER IN
A FAILED STATE FOR 2 DECADES,
JEN PSAKI CAN'T BE BOTHERED TO
TAKE THE TIME TO GIVE THEM THE
APPROPRIATE CREDIT.
TOUR AFTER TOUR THESE MEN AND
WOMEN SERVED.
HOW DOES THIS MAKE THE FAMILIES
OF SOLDIERS THAT DIED IN
AFGHANISTAN FEEL TONIGHT?
JEN, CIRCLE BACK AND DO AN
APOLOGY AT THE VERY LEAST.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BOTCHED THE WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN JUST LIKE THEY ARE
BOTCHING AMERICA'S ECONOMIC AND
POLITICAL INDEPENDENCE TO COVID.
UNDER BIDEN THE U.S. IS PRINTING
MONEY FASTER THAN ANY POINT IN
HISTORY AND INFLATION IS RUNNING
THROUGH THE ROOF.
MASSIVE PRICES AND SHORTAGES AND
A MASSIVE FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
EVERY AMERICAN.
THE COST OF A GALLON OF GASOLINE
IS $3 AND ABOVE IN MOST PLACES.
EVEN $5 AND HIGHER IN PLACES
LIKE CALIFORNIA.
DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS UNDER DONALD
TRUMP.
GREAT JOB, JOE.
THE COST TO HEAT AND COOL YOUR
HOME IS GOING THROUGH THE ROOF.
THE COST FOR GOODS AND SERVICES,
THAT'S COSTING MORE.
THAT'S BEING PASSED ON TO YOU AS
WELL.
NOW THERE IS A NATIONWIDE
SHORTAGE OF PATIO FURNITURE.
ADD IT TO THE LIST OF SHORTAGES
UNDER BIDEN.
BEEF, CHICKEN WINGS, LUMBER AND
GAS AND HISTORIC SHORTAGE OF
WORKERS.
THANKS TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
NEVER ENDING SHUTDOWNS AND HAND
OUTS, EMPLOYERS CAN'TED FINE
WORKERS.
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY THEY ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST. FIND
WORKERS.
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY THEY ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST.
A THIRD OF WORKERS ARE REFUSING
TO COME TO WORK AND THEY ARE
HAVING A PROBLEM HIRING POLICE.
SHOCKER?
THEY STRIPPED THEIR BUDGETS.
MANY POLICE DEPARTMENT ARE
OPERATING NOW AT REDUCED
CAPACITY.
THOSE THAT ARE WORKING, THEY ARE
AFRAID TO DO THEIR JOB BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THEY WON'T GET SUPPORT
FROM ELECTED EFFICIENCY.
-- OFFICIALS.
VIOLENT CRIME IS SPIKING IN ALL
OF THESE CITIES.
IT'S SO BAD AND DEMOCRATS ARE
PRETENDING REPUBLICANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT.
OTHERS DOUBLE DOWN ON THEIR
DEFUND DREAMS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION
IS WE MUST ELIMINATE FUNDING FOR
I.C.E. AND THEIR PARENT
ORGANIZATION.
TIME AFTER TIME WE HAVE SEEN IT.
AS HUMAN SERVICES AGENTS ON THE
GROUND WE SEE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THESE AGENCIES ARE INEPT.
>> Sean: DEFUND THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY?
YOU HAVE FORGOTTEN 9-11 AND
RADICAL ISLAMIC TERRORISTS AND
WHAT THEY DID THAT DAY.
STOP ENFORCING LAWS AT SOUTHERN
BORDER AND THIS WILL END.
CAN THEY BE THAT DUMP AND MANY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE TESTING
POSITIVE AT A HIGH RATE FOR
COVID.
WE HAVE OVERCROWDED CAGES THAT
BIDEN AND HARRIS BUILT IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC AND GIVING
THEM FREE TRANSPORTATIONS TO
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER IS
ANOTHER UNRESOLVED DISASTER.
THAT'S GETTING WORSE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS AN
ABSOLUTE SCHIFF SHOW.
WHOEVER IS IN CHARGE AT 1600
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE YOU A